a motorcyclist is dead and a juvenile is
in custody after a fatal accident in the
southwest part of town the victim
identified as 59-year-old kenneth lee
barker the young driver police say
showed signs of impairment at the scene
8 news now reporter sally jaramillo
joins us near patrick and tanea with
more on how barker is being remembered
sally
kirsten a memorial is going for kenneth
lee barker he is described as a great
guy who loved motorcycles and had a
heart of gold all the neighbors left and
shunked as he only lived a block away
it's a really sad day here in patrick
and tanea it all happened yesterday
evening las vegas metro police say
witnesses told them a honda accord
driven by a juvenile speeding eastbound
on patrick the young driver moved into
oncoming lanes to pass another vehicle
when suddenly they collided with a
motorcycle the victim's neighbors can't
believe it i just heard him leave
his house and then all of a sudden a few
minutes later i hear sirens and it's
like no it can't be robert f sober is
kenneth's neighbor he says he lived
behind him and was truly an amazing guy
who loved to ride motorcycles and was a
big nascar fan ken was a great guy and
to have somebody you know he's barely 60
years old to lose his life
he's going to the store
you know it's ridiculous that people
think they can just do whatever they
want sober says it's devastating to know
he's no longer with them this
neighborhood over here a lot of people
drive down patrick at excessive speeds
it's a 25 mile an hour zone and every
day i sit in my garage and i can see
people going by doing 60
70 miles an hour and says people need to
slow down ask for that juvenile it's
unacceptable he's going to pay for it
and it's sad that a young kid his whole
life is
totally changed due to one choice of
drinking and driving
charges have not been announced for the
juvenile police say the driver did show
signs of impairment i'm told kenneth has
a son and he is
definitely a grandparent as well and
that the community his neighbors are
currently working on creating a vigil
for him sally jaramillo live local now